a widely arrived in court knowing that
if these proceedings go against him he
could end up back behind bars as the de
facto head of South Korea's biggest
conglomerate that's a prospect that
would have wide repercussions Bannon
would be gone I feel very sorry for
causing concerns for many people Lee was
caught up in the corruption scandal that
brought down former president Park
geun-hye and her associate choice and
silla now both serving long prison terms
he was given a five-year sentence for
bribery but only served one year before
his sentence was cut in half on appeal
and he was able to walk free but the
prosecution appealed that decision and
won a ruling at the Supreme Court which
is now resulted in this retrial the case
has also highlighted the long-standing
controversy over the role of South
Korea's jab all these are family-run
conglomerates that dominate the economy
and are often accused of wielding too
much power
prosecution lawyers have told the court
that Lee's alleged bribery was part of a
plan to take over the chairmanship of
Samsung from his father it poses a
challenge to the current liberal
administration of president moon jae-in
seen here at a recent ceremony with lee
unveiling a multi-billion dollar
investment moon has promised to curb the
chaebol powers but it comes at a
difficult time for South Korea and
Samsung as the tech giant faces a global
downturn in semiconductor sales as well
as the fallout from the us-china trade
war and trade restrictions imposed by
Japan which Lee has been trying to fix
CEO idly has been credited with leading
Samsung Electronics to find replacement
chemicals for export restricted Japanese
chemicals and he's been getting very
good public opinion over that but if now
he goes to prison there's a question on
whether Samsung can maintain that kind
of pace representing 20 percent of South
Korea's exports Samsung may be
too big to fail but it's boss might not
be too big to be sent back to jail
Rob McBride al Jazeera Seoul